foreign
my name is Matt this is probably going
to be a VOD so I'm going to treat it a
bit like that like I'm doing a recording
a bit uh also I will be watching chat
because I'm doing this live
so what I'm doing here for context is
I'm taking this very first game that I
ever made in opengl I made this for a
class in college and a for a graphics
class
it's pretty bad from a programming
standpoint game development standpoint
so it's definitely a lot of things that
need or could be upgraded but first of
all this was originally made on Linux
for Linux so all this code and all the
build systems are very Linux specific
there's also a few branches I have the
original I think this original was the
one I actually submitted but I think
there's some stuff that might have
copyright problems here or something
like that because I think I used some
sound effects that were stolen from the
Internet or whatever I guess I'll start
with original an update from there
but the main goals of this are to just
make it a little more playable make it a
little better make it look a little
better this is technically or what it's
supposed to be rather is A Haunted House
game where you have to escape the
haunted house and then you win it's very
simple uh once you exit the house the
game just ends there's no proper ending
really
so it's just it was kind of something I
got done enough to get the grade and I
had to make a lot of hacks because I
didn't know how to do things and stuff
like that
so for a lot of this I was just like I
just need to get it to work by tomorrow
I don't know what I'm doing that kind of
stuff but anyway we're gonna take it
from Linux to a Windows build
and in uh we'll address any of the
libraries we need to on Windows but yeah
the goal is basically to get building on
Windows and start making improvements
because as you'll see once you start
going through their code
there's a I know off the top of my head
there was some hacks I did just to get
it done because I was out of time so I'm
going to talk about those a little bit
and why they're bad and what we can do
better and stuff like that
so first we're going to look at it just
with the terminal for a moment and
address some main things about files
pretty straightforward files yeah I was
working with vs code I think I'm just
going to use visual studio just because
it's easier but we're going to also take
this from make file to cmake
and we're gonna probably use a package
manager to do the libraries because the
other option is to like manually set
them up and do like
get sub modules or you know we could do
that and I've got videos on that on my
coding Channel probably where you're
watching this after the fact if you're
curious about how to do that
so yeah we got a lot of we got a lot of
little Basics to do let me get to the
branch I want so hit check out uh
original
let's make sure we're up to date here
cool and let's make a new Branch get
branch
uh 20 23 update I might do this like
once a year or something I don't know
update stream sure
I just wanted to be trackable if someone
wants to like go view the changes from
this video you'll kind of see what to do
in theory all right so from here let's
see what do we want to do I think I'll
just go ahead and
start cleaning things up a bit remove
this dot vs code that shouldn't be in
here to begin with
everything else is okay for now yeah
launch Visual Studio at this point
and
well let's make Visual Studio is going
to be a little confused by this
see I could like you know start tweaking
the files here the other thing I could
do is I could just make a new directory
and start copying in stuff that's needed
do it that way I think we'll just make a
cmake list the new item command
and then I'll just code it
SN Visual Studio code
and just put some basics in here
a lot of people say I'm gonna love
Visual Studio code but I I don't really
use that much so you make minimum
required version I'll just go with like
three Dot 15.
tend to use features up to that right
now
and let's go project
we only Escape
first 1.1 I guess there's no other
versions tagged I may look stupid
doesn't really matter there's only an
executable here
which is uh I'll just name it Escape
okay we need all the source files so
there's a couple ways of doing this
there's a blob I guess for now
that's the source I'll call it code in
this example since it's in a code I
think I'll update it I'll put it in I'll
end up putting it in a source directory
so it's going to begin
source start.cp and we'll get the
headers too
and that's what we're compiling okay so
something like that
and I'll just go like move code to
source
that should change that file name yeah
okay
then our make file we aren't going to
need it anymore all right but that's
good enough we should at least be able
to open this
for now so
Visual Studio continue without code then
file open cmake
find it in here
and we should be able to take it from
here Google just the editor let's see
what the original make file looked like
okay so I was using
sdl for all the sound stuff
during this time
and this is just all the opengl stuff
but I think I was using sdl for all the
windowing as well check out some okay
with but I don't think my package
manager has all that let's do a quick
search
sdl to see that as my head in the way
now we can see it okay so phase one of
this is basically going to be to get it
running on windows with new libraries so
once we get through that phase we're
going to move on to phase two which will
be basically updating any broken code
and stuff like that okay we got
everything STL is here this should be
fine
I think we'll go past C plus plus 11 too
we might as well yeah here's a here's a
pretty
pretty classy make file
kind of the way I used to always do my
build system so something like this but
we're not going to need that anymore
I'm just gonna need it for a reference
here for these libraries basically
the rest don't care about too much
it's easy to figure out
so make a note here uh it's lives we
need
those so we're gonna have to get all
those
just end up doing a Target link
libraries
private
and we'll see what these are called
another thing we're going to add here is
a manifest for these libraries for the
VC PKG so we'll go new item BC
bkg.json just doing it at the root of
this project show up there yep looks
good
and then we need to fill this out and
tell it what libraries we want
so we need a name and I think I'll just
go with has to be all lower case we'll
just go with Escape think we need a
version string
I'll go with 1.0 and we need
dependencies
so this is where we're going to list all
the libraries
that we need basically let's open this
to the side here like this
isn't this exciting
I think I'll do like a little coffee
break every I don't know hour or so or
whenever I tired of coding and just
answer any questions in the comments but
for now I'm not really watching comments
I'll check you guys out soon it's just
going to talk like I'm talking to a
video recording basically okay so we're
gonna need GL I think we have all this
stuff we'll just get glue glue is good
enough here
uh sdl now we got to go off the names
that is so there's sdl
scale two
doing this slightly wrong I'll fix in a
second if I am we need stl2 mixer
and Main the main might just come with
sdl too
I don't see a main listed here
I just need sdl to mixer
because that's all we need for the
moment I don't think we're going to use
glut
I don't remember what all we needed it
for to begin with but we'll address it
if we need to we should just need just
this stuff this should be fine enough
because sdl will get us the windowing
stuff the mixer will give us the sound
glue load all the extensions for opengl
I think that's all we're going to need
okay but this seems to be somewhat wrong
so I'm going to cross reference one of
my other projects here and see what
we're doing wrong all these need to be
in quotes
I believe we're also going to need glm
okay let's see if it's happy with that
oh it's not going to be happy with this
target link Library part oops that
shortly
okay but at this point we should get
some kind of feedback here
cool it's going to download all the
libraries this might take a moment I
guess I can look and see if there's any
chat now
nothing okay
makes it easy
I guess I should probably still make
this Linux compatible
so we could do like an if Unix type
setup
somewhere
maybe we'll just get that ready
that's good
refined package
I don't know if these are all going to
work properly on Linux
okay we'll just forget about Max for now
we'll just make sure it works on Windows
and we can mess with Linux later if we
want maybe that'll be a part two
people are interested
but the way it was originally I already
worked with Linux so it's just mostly
just need to adapt the cmake to consider
Linux 2.
all right so this canceled how it's
because I added it to cmake
you are viewing
now would be a fine time to chat or let
me know what you're working on or any
comments thoughts whatever
I have no idea how many people watch my
live streams I typically just keep the
viewers hidden in general so
I prefer just not to know in general I I
just don't want to change my mentality
whether I have very few or a ton I would
rather just stay the same
okay so when this builds the libraries
we should get it should tell us
basically what we need in our cmake here
yeah so blind package blue wire then
we'll do Target link libraries
basically just copying what's down here
I know my head might be in the way but
uh
shouldn't be able to figure it out
actually I'll just copy it
copy pasta action there's sdl2 looks
like they've got some interesting
config on that generator expressions
let's do each library on a new line As a
complicated generator expression Target
name if exists STL stl2 main if it
exists
okay
that's the code it gave me though so it
should be fine and we're going to add in
the mixer
and we got a similar line of code for
that
glm here
and we'll link glm
okay so that should generically be
enough to get us started let's see let's
see if we can just compile from here
because in theory we should we got the
source we got the libraries it should
work but it's probably going to have an
error or two so don't expect it to work
no okay so it has problems with glut I
think we can just get rid of glut
foreign
for like all the screen controls
okay so I might update this because I
think what is pretty out of date I might
update this to glfw
let's let's just see if glut is still
available search a lot it is
we got free glut
so we can we can do glut that's fine
once this uh change as little as
possible in this port
so pretty glut
add that to the library manifest
uncommon it where we there we go come
with that
and we need to add it to our cmake as
well but first we can just regenerate
our cmake cache so that it downloads the
library and installs it
and it should tell us basically what we
need to put in our cmake
I think these GL links are implied or
maybe they're applied through the clue
or glut so I don't think we need to
address these first too we'll see if we
do lead we'll do it okay there's fine
package
uh we need several packages for this I
guess I'll just do what it says line
package
reglot configure required but it also
has
this one here
yes them both
so we'll just put those in there link
those
and just see what happens
okay cmake was successful let's build
this runs first try I'm gonna be it runs
okay well we get a blank blue screen I
probably failed to load the resources
yeah it didn't find our shaders and that
sort of stuff so we got a little file
directory problems but it actually
builds
so that's interesting I did not expect
it to build without changing into code
actually
um that's cool though
okay so we're good on the libraries
I'm not going to mess with the code yet
code is definitely going to require some
overhaul now we just need to straighten
out the shaders it doesn't know where
the shaders are
we have a fragment of our text Shader
and let's see where we load these
shader.h probably okay now this is just
some boilerplate to do the main stop
we need to find where we're specifying
our paths to these shaders because that
is it's in our source and this is
building somewhere else so I guess what
we need to do we have a couple different
options here we could take these shaders
and we could hard code them in somewhere
into the C plus plus or we could copy
these two
the build directory that way it could
find them easier because that'll be an
out build
let's go ahead and open this up
executables right here we could copy the
shaders here too so maybe we'll just do
that so that's kind of easy to do
that's a quick and easy solution
so we can just go file to copy
directory I need to look this up I
forget if you make copy a folder
a bit
yeah I was on the right track file copy
and then we want to go
see make current sourcer
always forget how to do this exactly
yeah I forget if it allows us to specify
a folder let's just try it see if it
does and destination it'll be Smacker
this and keep cmake I think it's binary
over okay let's see what this does we'll
have to observe this out directory and
see what happens okay push the shaders
in here but it doesn't put them in a
folder we'd prefer to have them in a
folder
so I think we gotta do this let's try
let's delete that like that
but oh it didn't reset okay I need to uh
regenerate this yeah we get a shaders
folder this way okay so that will copy
our shaders folder to this other one and
a a Works imagine that I think it did
not load all the audio
so we need to do a file copy of the
resources but hey we can move around to
first person game
we're almost done with step one oh it
has a problem my mouse goes off the
screen
if I move it fast enough
my mouse is not locking the screen okay
that's an issue we'll definitely have to
fix I think when I built this I built
this on a laptop that only had one
screen so I didn't know that it would go
off your screen to your other screens
but yeah we'll just copy these resources
the same way we did the shaders
isn't exactly my favorite way of doing
this actually because oh I don't want to
be copying a bunch of binaries every
build but
well
we just want to get it done you can
worry about optimizing an efficiency
later Pro tip don't optimize too soon
just get it working especially when
you're on a deadline
I must escape yeah this is the game
there's the footsteps
to play through the game I might as well
play through I'm going to turn this
volume down though I don't know if this
is going to affect it on the Stream So
warning loud sound warning I'm pretty
sure there are really loud sounds in
this
all right so basically you're in this
house yeah it's really generic looking I
think I only used one square and a bunch
of transforms to do this whole thing so
there's only like one box in memory if
you will
so it doesn't really tell you in this
game but basically you have to get out
this front door
but you got to figure out what to do
black triangle
here
something in here I know what to do but
I'm just moving around for sake
by snowing I guess
so it's not exactly a challenge
foreign
little find this triangle this is
supposed to be I ran out of time and
didn't know how to do it at the time
what's supposed what it's supposed to be
is this here is supposed to be like a
wall that looks half broken and could be
broken through with a tool or something
that's what it's supposed to be
and this is supposed to be a tool or a
bomb or something to break the wall
[Music]
big enough to get a little sound but
that's what it's supposed to be and then
this turns white after you pick it up
to give you a hint because I couldn't
think of a better way to do it on my
deadline
so why do you want to blow it up
where do you go
okay so you blowing up
and uh figure out what it did
what it does is it moves this wall how
would you know that I don't know
I've got to get this little Hatchet
[Music]
then once you get the little Hatchet
gotta go break down the front door and
then you escape you're gonna do this
before the ceiling squishes you
or you die
that's that's all the game is okay I'll
win the game this time I must escape
[Music]
Mouse control issues okay Mouse control
issues are real bad
I was definitely the only person in my
class I've got first person stuff
working no one else had anything first
person working everyone just had like a
little 2D thing
that's the game oh yeah there's also a
jump for some reason I must escape
there was gonna be like jump stuff in
the game but I didn't have time to
actually editing that okay well it works
on windows so phase one is done we have
the build working on Windows
um I think we can commit this
okay well we don't have a proper git
ignore so we need to fix that
and we can delete our old make file now
we don't need that okay so let's fix up
our git ignore I'm just going to use one
for my other project copied over
because otherwise I'll be here figuring
out little things to type for ages
there we go all this stuff that should
cover everything
now when we go to our get changes it
should cut out a lot of stuff okay it
doesn't have vs code in it
we'll just add that somewhere
or maybe it does okay it's saying it's
deleting it all right that's fine no
this is fine
like we actually need that line
the obvious code already in here all
right okay
build on Windows
wait I'm on the original Branch I don't
want to be on the original Branch Uh
crap
I thought I'd switch to this branch
otherwise switch this thing I just
committed or undo this commit without
losing all my changes
uh that's too much that's too much brain
power required I'm not going to worry
about it we're just going to push it
done and done but yeah I was not
supposed to be on this Branch I was
supposed to be on this one I made
earlier but whatever it's fine
it's still in its original state it's
just it builds on Windows now
and to get it to build on Linux still
I'd have to go try it on Linux and test
some stuff but it shouldn't require too
many changes to do that basically we'd
have to do the same thing
except make sure they have it on Linux
might actually be like exactly the same
actually
but yeah that's good enough so let's do
another thing here let's say I want to
give an example in this video of how to
uh like ship this to your friends and
let them play it because yeah you could
tell them to like compile it and you
know go to GitHub learn how to compile
et cetera et cetera but your friends
aren't going to do that so what you can
do is you can ship it to them like
they're used to seeing games by just
putting install here
install this thing
what else do we need we double check
check my references here
install targets
and then we also want to make sure they
get these shaders and sound
stuff because I'm gonna need that so
we'll go install files
but we also need to make sure they get
the dlls required for these libraries so
we need to do that as well
so the way we're going to do that is
through another file
all the variables we call runtime dll
that's from the current binary deals so
get all those
just make sure they get all these two
I think that's all we need oh we need
these files too okay I think in this
case we go let's do some more Globs
I guess we could do
this earlier and then do the file copy I
might be doing a little redundant work
here where I could combine some of these
commands using this Shader variable I'm
about to make but I'm not going to worry
about that right now I'm just going to
continue on but if you want to do that
as an experiment or test or whatever
for it
glso okay just go and install on that I
guess I'll call it runtime shaders and
rather than bin I think we're gonna go
Gators
well Ben shaders that's what we need to
do
fine and we'll do a similar thing for
the sound stuff
this word resources sound I think
they're all dot wave files because I
need to check
they're all dot wave files
and we'll put those in bin resources
sound that should be good
sure we can take this to run type sounds
sorry if my head's in the way this code
I'll bring it up here at least once so
yeah this is kind of ugly I definitely
refactor this later to put these files
earlier and just make it a little
cleaner but this is fine enough
I'll walk through this real quick we're
going to install the target that's the
executable
we're gonna find all the dlls we need
put them in the bin which is where the
executable goes we're going to find all
the runtime shaders
also put them in there so it knows where
to find them at runtime all for the
install
and I believe you can use the CPAC
extension here too to make a like make
an actual installer
which we might try to do next if we want
but I have to dig into remember how to
do that a little more
all right let's go ahead and update the
cmake now we should get an install
option
okay cool
let's also add another config or just
like Min size release Here
I'm going to name this release Min
changes to Min size release and that
should build without debug symbols for
the one we want to ship in theory
holy crap comets
okay take a moment to read through these
hey hey
thanks NyQuil God I don't know what your
name is I'm just going to call you
NyQuil God I guess it's
nyqbgcd which looks like night club all
right
cool I'm glad you're learning from this
that's awesome John says my sleep
schedule is an Abomination on the
contrary I just got up at six a.m and
started doing work I think my sleep
schedule's on point
today at least
okay I'll read another question here at
the end uh I mean this question has been
irrelevant but I always wondered why we
type each Source into file instead of
just saying include all CPU files oh
like this glob thing well it's because
of how cmake works actually
um
it actually handles it better than it
used to but they used to say never ever
do this because if you add or removed
source files over here then by this
definition it won't know that but that's
not entirely true you just have to make
sure you go over to your cmake and hit
save to put a new time stamp on it and
regenerate and it'll update but if you
manually list out every file it will you
also if you add a new file you have to
go edit this so you by Nature have to
update the timestamp so that's the only
reason that I know of that they say
don't use glob but I don't care like I
I'm aware of this fact so it's not an
issue for me okay let's get this
installed going and make sure it works
uh switch to release so you guys like my
first game ever I built this
so long ago it's very nostalgic for me
and I haven't touched it for years
because of this Nostalgia factor of I
didn't want to change it but here we are
finally making a change
okay
let's make sure it builds and release
Must Escape
beat the game real quick
this game is so janky I lost my mouse
again okay there we go
break down this thing
the workout behind the secret wall get
jacks
go over here and
try to break out before I die
oh there's plenty of time I got time
this is fine
[Music]
okay yeah there's the wall it slides
outside the house it's janky all right
um so it runs in the release let's
install it now so we go to install hit
this install button and it says there's
an issue with the free glot dll doesn't
find it okay let's fix that so we need
to
go to that out folder and see what's
going on here there we go out install
release bin
it's got that it's got oh it didn't copy
the DLS there are no dlls here so what's
the problem there
current binary dur
okay so it should be copying them from
the build this folder and it's not
why not
I don't know it's weird
all right thanks for the compliments
NyQuil God appreciate that
on the first game
it's took a surprisingly long a lot of
time it's very jankiest as you'll see
once we get to the code here
so as soon as this install works I will
jump to that and we'll we'll look at the
code we got a lot of a lot of fixes
mainly like I only had one square for
the whole thing in one triangle so
that's all it's built on but it would
and the mouse goes off the screen so
that's issue art install
okay it's fine it just didn't copy the
deals the first time
this time it did
yeah they're there all right so like
this bin file right here we can you
could send this to your friends and tell
them to run the executable and it would
it would work
the only Escape is escape so I can just
double click this escape and yes if you
press the Escape key it closes the game
that's that was the joke it's terrorists
terrible joke
uh but yeah usually from this point I
just like zip it up or something and
send it to people if I want to do that
or have them test it
which I guess I could put in my Discord
somewhere you guys want it
I don't know if it's worth Distributing
because it's sort of terrible but that's
a way you can do it for example I want
to at least get that in the video
uh the main thing is while they need to
be using the same OS like Windows here
for example these dlls just all the
runtime files which for in my case the
dlls for the library the shaders and the
resources
and whatever however your executable
runs needs to path to all this stuff
correctly which for the dll's same
directory for other stuff it's just
however it was in your code like when we
go look in our code you're going to see
it's going to look in a shaders folder
and a resource sounds folder
so those are the the core things
but if you want to just give them a uh
installer that does all this and then
let's test them put it in their
directory and stuff use CPAC and it goes
off of however you have your install set
up I'm not going to do that right now
with something you can research later if
you want I just uh I'd have to do
research to remember how to do that
exactly but it's pretty easy actually
paddle with Windows 10 and 11 should be
I haven't tested 11 but I don't see why
not
but yeah they won't have to build it or
anything they just need to run the
executable and as long as they have like
a graphics card that runs opengl it'll
be fine but everybody does because
that's Legacy stuff
all right now part two the code
let's install
but this end Theory should also build
and install on Linux currently too as
long as they have the libraries
cool all right let's let's optimize some
code this code is garbage right now all
right as you'll find out very shortly
here let's see how did I even do this
I have a main let's start with the main
two okay this code is already so ugly
right off the bat I have a window width
window height set last text last y oh
this is for like Mouse centering stuff
a full screen screen commented out okay
I have Glutton knit with the args the
knit display
I don't even know what this does anymore
actually a bunch of C out stuff
include game let's see what this game
has X turns from the main okay yeah
don't do this
never do this apparently it works but
you're not supposed to do that so I
guess this looks like I set up the
square and triangle here and the camera
and the Shader do some Delta Time stuff
for between frames
these are probably all the Callback
stuff for all my pressing keys Mouse
click Mouse click hold wait there's a
click hold
oh I have a drag Motion Set up
apparently I didn't know that I don't
think we even used that
but I have all these like debug C outs
in here which uh
they don't want either there's no way
I'm gonna get this properly refactored
in about the hour I have left but I'll
get as far as I can
okay State main menu or play there is no
main menu in this game so I think I just
skipped over that it's just always in
play
knit all callbacks okay so this just
sets up all these probably take a look
yeah so when you hit play it and it's
all callbacks
I should be in some kind of
initialization because this is really
ugly code
okay so here's where it creates the
Shader and this is where that folder
directory is specified that's why it
looks for shaders in a Shader folder
from where they executed boys so it's
literally that's hard coded in right
here and it's going to be the same for
wherever I load the sounds and resources
okay this is all the callbacks using
glut so I think glut was overall
replaced with glfw
I have play sounds
game callbacks
oh no
close your eyes kids you can't see this
don't don't look okay this is adults
only all right don't look
don't judge me don't judge old coder me
this is the ugliest code ever okay I'll
explain why this is so bad okay so I
have a function called update display
that I probably call every frame
right and I remember at the time I was
doing this the night before it was due
and I couldn't figure out a better way
so I'm like I'm just gonna just gonna
put everything in here and just get it
to work and that's literally what I did
so
I tried to have it so that it had a
night and day cycle so I literally just
hard coded based on Delta time
different colors of
the uh the background of the clear
screen to like emulate a sky box that
just changed colors but it just like
suddenly shifts to hard different colors
so you don't really notice that in the
game because you're in a house the whole
time so but it's really bad it's pretty
ugly
there's a time of day thing in the
Shader that updates it
I think
I honestly don't know what I was doing
there all right but something like that
this clear color doesn't need to change
anything on the Shader though so I don't
know why I was setting the time of day
on the shade or two not really sure
I think I might have been mixing it with
like the walls and everything to try to
emulate a change of color
all right then we have a GL clear color
I guess that's okay
then we update our projection in case we
moved
this should in theory only update when
you actually move because if this just
updates when it doesn't need to it's
going to be inefficient but it's not
that bad
same with the view should only update
when we actually move so there I should
have some kind of like moved flag rather
than just setting this every time all
right and now here's where it gets
really janky
I have a render box I called the
surrender box it's just a model Matrix
and literally for every square that I
draw I update this model Matrix and set
a color and then push it to the Shader
and then do a draw and this one is the
red wall
I guess so like for every single Square
in that game I have something like this
and there's always some Boolean around
it depending on the game state for like
some of the things that change during
the game so there's this one
and it draws at the end once it gets
everything set up so it's like this is
some sort of game State for the red wall
apparently in The Orange Room item
then it goes on to the next thing okay
apparently okay this is the outside
ground do the same thing update this
model Matrix draw it
and then I have an area for the
collapsing roof ceiling
some if the main door HP is greater than
zero and The Orange Room item is
collected and the red wall is destroyed
time till dead updates the Delta time
collapsing roof goes down 0.3 of a flow
I should have this Delta timed probably
oh if it's greater than .03 I don't know
why it's doing that then the collapsing
roof goes down
this number times the Delta time
than if dead sound played and time till
dead is greater than that play dead
sound dead sound played equals to oh my
God I think the first time I put this in
here it was just looping you are dead
you were dead you were dead like every
time so I had to put this Boolean to
make it stop and it was the time till
dead is over this time it just it just
exits it just closes
oh goodness I can't believe how funny
this is to me and I think I had to tweak
this so that was just enough time to
play the sound
and then close because if I didn't do
this it would just like start playing
the sound and close immediately or
something all right then this is only
what like an eighth of the way through
the file this just goes on this is just
like messy logic in a giant file of just
every little thing in the game that
happens so I guess this is the majority
of the game Loop but the fact that I was
manually doing okay every for every
single Square reset the model back to
the model Matrix back to default do a
translate scale set it on the Shader
draw that one reset it translate it
scale it set it on the Shader draw it
like every frame just doing this or not
in frame like
a bunch of times per frame this is very
inefficient but it doesn't matter
because the game's so small anyway that
it's not really going to hurt anything
but like I remember tweaking all these
numbers to try to get all these squares
in the right place to make it look like
a proper box
this must be the collapsing roof because
I think wait I don't know what this is
collapsing roof I've seen roof well I
don't have that in here at lunch times I
don't remember
this is more acceptable in 2D for sure
but in 3D you should probably have a
system
that is in a giant Cascade of logic
because can you imagine trying to update
this or change your level it could
change my level I literally have to like
manually tweak these hit run tweak run
and just like it's a really slow process
oh my goodness I don't know if I can
manage to really update this right now
after all this is this is very painful
at least I have comments I'll say that
says like what this stuff was supposed
to do I think I had to because I
literally couldn't find it in the code
if I didn't above front door oh and also
uh
I guess you can see this if I run it
I must escape
like this orange wall this isn't one
square this is like there's like a
square for this section and then a
square for I don't know it's hard to
point correctly and then a square above
the door and then a square over here so
I had to draw like three different
squares for these a lot of these walls
and same with this one one big square
one up here and one over there and as
you can see like that one's a little off
I don't know if you can see it but this
one
my camera's reversed so this is awkward
but there's a little jaggy there I just
didn't get it perfect because I probably
gave up and looks like it's close enough
right side wall of the door left side
wall the door so there's like big
vertical walls
it's it's just it's very Jank but it's
done and I think I got a good grade on
it
better than the latest Call of Duty
thanks for hanging hanging out NyQuil
NyQuil God
enjoy your day
all right well this just kind of goes on
so
game Idol what the heck is this
game Idol this is uh I think this is
just the standard
oh this is the jump of rise and fall
this is just the movement okay so this
is the movement it's not idle I don't
know why it's called idle here's the
click stuff
oh The Click trigger interact area do
you want to see Jank
okay so the interaction areas I'd like
manually programmed positions in the
world and if you click when you're in
them stuff happens so that's how the
door is open there's like an area in the
world that if you press click while
you're in that position
then it interacts with door there's no
Ray casting or anything like that you
just got to be in a certain spot and
then click that's that's literally how
the clicks work in this game
so this is gonna this is too much I've
decided at this point that this is too
much work to refactor this would take me
like days and it would not be worth my
time because it's it's terrible but
we'll make a few minutes like I'll
initialize this front Vector there look
at me optimizing
fixing code oh my goodness was this time
since last step time between footsteps
Max look angle wait is that really a
thing
I gotta check this out I must escape oh
I can only look up 35 degrees
interesting uh program that in there
it's as high as I can look up
big
see if I'll look down oh there's another
wall Jank problem right there
you can only look down 30. so I locked
it
to only be able to 35 degree angle look
okay I guess that's fine Zoom I think
this is
like a field of view let's just up this
to 90. see what this looks like with 90
fov I must oh look at that
heck yeah
ready to do some first person shooting
it actually looks better but it looks
almost too big
I guess that might be a change worth
doing but see what 60 looks like
Must Escape
that's probably better okay I can at
least say I've updated some code at this
point
there's the movement which is a static
struct
it's just hard-coded in a header as a
static oh no don't do this either
this is painful what else do I have in
here
primitive objects
oh I have hard coded in the positions of
the triangle and Cube that's not too bad
and apparently I had a circle ready but
I never used it so I don't think this is
used let's see if it compiles without it
I must escape yeah there's no circles in
this game so we didn't need that
I think that was planning on drawing
circles with the Shader just based on a
radius or something I don't know I
really don't remember but didn't end up
using that solid Zone oh this is this is
why in the game you can't walk through
walls it's literally this stuff there's
certain positions
where if you run into them you don't
move this is all just manually
programmed in there's no physics in this
game it's just
solid zones as I called them or just
wouldn't let you move God all right the
sound so I'm going to do the sounds
um I think I just loaded up some
footstep files and some grunt files
I think I found most of these on the
internet
those are the jumps these are the one
two three four five six different
footsteps that it randomizes between I
think
so you get like a variety or closed door
open yeah install this little stuff pick
up sound
I think I had some sounds that I never
used there's the Guile Theme the win
that's definitely copyrighted there's
the chop sound
I don't know what music box is I don't
know what runaway is I don't know what
demo is I don't think I even use these
oh this demolition let's explode then oh
that's when you blow up the door okay
music box
oh this is supposed to be playing while
you're playing the game I don't think it
is for some reason play default music
I don't know there's definitely supposed
to be some little background music play
that's like creepy but
all right so there's also no Lighting in
this game all right there's there's more
terrible code don't worry I'm just not
showing all of it but this you can go
look at it if you want to GitHub let's
look at how bad the shaders are
frag Shader just outputs a color no
textures no lighting just solid colors
the vertex Shader the heck is this oh
time of day and color end so I set these
for different walls
oh and it's just a bunch of if color
color equals
ambient time of daylighting oh this is
commented out I didn't even use this so
there's code that sets this and I don't
even use it I think I didn't like the
way it looked but I never took it out of
the code I guess uh I can do you know I
can do that that's one thing I can do to
fix it say I did something
let's find out where it did this team
callbacks yeah okay some of the
callbacks so the callbacks are like what
run
yeah this whole time of day thing it
doesn't even use this so there's like
literally no point in the select code
because
switch to represent representation of
sky
doesn't use this
okay yeah it doesn't use any of this
so the better way to do this would just
be to have an actual light and have it
change and move rather than like
manually hard coding and all this stuff
so yeah it should still work the same
without that I must escape
because I literally did nothing all
right we fixed it
I think that's all I can bear of uh
working on this
this was actually worse than I thought
it was gonna be but we did did some good
work I think showing the the switching
it to Windows it's showing the install
kind of showing how you can go over the
code and update shaders that's probably
enough for this video and yeah that's
all that's all I'm going to do on this I
hope you enjoyed
I'm just gonna give you something